-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
Senator Bernie Sanders.
There have been a lot of major
labor victories this year,
but you have been lamenting
that we don't,
in the modern era,
seem to have as many labor songs
in popular music as we have
in previous eras
of the pro-labor movement.
Does that bum you out?
You've reached out and basically
said to artists,
"Let's have some."
-Well, you know,
you don't want to hear me sing.
That you don't want to hear.
No.
But what I know, and you know,
and I think most people know
is that a great song
can capture the souls of people
and bring people together.
And you think about
Woody Guthrie and Pete Seeger
and all of those people,
and the music that they wrote
and that they sang spoke to
what was going on in the country
and the need for
human solidarity,
for everybody supporting
everybody else
and for people coming together
to stand up and fight, you know,
for justice.
So I love that stuff.
I'm a big fan of Woody Guthrie,
all these guys.
And what we are going to do is
try to get the best songwriters
and musicians that we can --
we can find to talk about
contemporary issues,
not the 1930s,
but what's going on right now
in 2022
and see what we can do
with that.
-Do you listen to any sort of
non-pro-labor music?
[ Laughter ]
-Occasionally, yeah.
-Occasionally.
Hey, I want to ask
about your brother.
So your brother -- you were over
sort of doing rallies
for the rail workers
in the U.K.,
and your brother is a politician
over there.
This is your brother, Larry.
-Yes, it is.
-Larry Sanders.
-Yep.
-When you grew up, was it a --
is this a surprise,
that you both got into
progressive politics?
-Well, I would not be sitting
here with you today
if it wasn't
for my brother.
My brother bought --
my parents --
my father dropped out of school
when he was 14.
And we didn't have a whole lot
of books in the house.
And my brother really shaped
my education in many respects.
So I love him very much.
Just had the opportunity to see
him and a lot of my nieces
and nephews in London,
so we had a great time.
Did you know, by the way --
so this is his logo,
and I'm wondering if he asked
or who had it first,
because that's --
[ Laughter ]
He has been active in
the Green Party over there.
And he was on
the Oxfordshire county council
for a number of years.
-Did you guys ever threaten
your parents
as a form of rebellion
of maybe being conservative
politicians?
-Did we form a union?
A brothers union?
-Go on strike? No.
-Unionize.
-[ Laughs ]
I remember, you guys, 'cause at
the time, your allowance was --
it was unlivable.
You couldn't have
a livable wage.
-Go on strike
for more allowance.
That's an idea. Now it's gonna
spread all over this country.
I see kids now, organizing.
You've had the pleasure of
campaigning for each other
over the years.
That must be a surreal moment,
to get up and be able to talk
about somebody you probably know
better than anyone to voters.
-Well, you know, we grew up
in a 3 1/2 room,
rent-controlled apartment
in Brooklyn.
Y'all heard of Brooklyn?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's the first anyone here
thought you were from New York.
[ Laughter ]
-It's the Vermont accent.
-It's so thick,
your Vermont accent.
-But, you know, I used to,
you know, go tramping around
with him, knocking on doors
and stuff, when we were young.
-So he's been in the U.K.
for quite a while.
Has he lost his Brooklyn accent?
-It's kind of a weird mixture
of English accent
plus Brooklyn accent.
-'Cause, you know, that's a --
it's a real --
-But I can't understand
my nieces and nephews.
I got to say, that's hard.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, we definitely
appreciate your honesty.
-So, what -- you know,
I think -- you know,
if I can just bring it back to
midterms one more time,
it does seem like, you know, the
left has been,
I don't know, energized by the
worst possible reason,
which was Dobbs.
And then you have --
so maybe the left is surging
ahead based on abortion,
but it does seem like the right
dominates the economy,
as it gets closer
and closer to an election.
What do politicians in the
Democratic Party have to do?
-Look, what you have to say is,
be honest
about what Republicans
stand for.
Republicans have made clear,
Mitch McConnell and others,
that they want to cut
Social Security,
Medicare, and Medicaid.
I think that's a horrible thing
to do, but it's bad politically.
The entire world is worried
about the crisis
of climate change, and
these guys are really indebted
to the fossil fuel industry.
They're not gonna do anything
on it.
Many of us want to raise the
minimum wage to a living wage.
I introduced legislation
for 15 bucks an hour,
which is not enough now.
We had zero Republican support.
So I think if you look
at the Republican Party,
issue by issue, you know,
it is clear
that they are the party
that represents the wealthy
and the powerful.
Are the Democrats doing enough
for working people?
No. But I think the contrast
between the two
is strong enough that I would
hope that all over this country,
people reject
this right-wing extremism
and put Democrats back in office
in the House and the Senate.
-Well, I really appreciate you
making the time, as always.
Keep up the good fight in D.C.
For us,
and we'll see you next time.
-Okay, thank you.
-Senator Bernie Sanders,
everybody.